es el último adiós para daria dukina las
flores y la música acompañaron a los
familiares amigos y seguidores en el
funeral de la periodista defensora de la
política exterior del presidente ruso
vladimir putin su padre un ideólogo
ultra nacionalista defensor de la
unificación de los territorios de habla
rusa aseguró que su memoria sólo podrá
ser honrada con una victoria de moscú
ante quien
ella murió en el frente por la nación
por rusia el frente está aquí en cada
uno de nosotros 7
el asesinato del domina el sábado en un
coche bomba ha conmocionado una parte de
la ciudadanía rusa lo tildan de un
crimen cargado de motivos ideológicos
esta tragedia
esta tragedia hace caer las máscaras de
los responsables de todo esto de los que
nos odian porque somos rusos que odian
nuestra fe porque somos ortodoxos miran
y absolvieron damos como pruebas tomé
las preguntas sobre la muerte de douglas
siguen abiertas pero el lunes el
servicio de seguridad federal de rusia
acusó a los servicios secretos de
ucrania de su asesinato además la
hipótesis más sonada es que el atentado
iba dirigido hacia su padre putin por su
parte calificó el ataque de malvado un
adjetivo que hace eco en las
declaraciones de su ministro de
relaciones exteriores
no puedo juzgar si fue un acto de
intimidación o un ajuste de cuentas creo
que esto fue un crimen bárbaro para el
que no puede haber perdón y quienes lo
organizaron según tengo entendido el fsb
ya ha establecido los hechos que ahora
están siendo investigados e
investigaciones pero se completará
rápidamente y como resultado de esta
investigación por supuesto no puede
haber piedad para los organizadores
instigadores y perpetradores de este
crimen y su confusión desde ucrania
aseguran no tener ningún tipo de
responsabilidad en el crimen lo
catalogan de propaganda y temen que sea
una estrategia rusa para encontrar mayor
apoyo en su ofensiva en territorio
ucraniano